10 Marvel Movie Mysteries That Need Answers
Badly
In any given interconnected movie universe,
there will always be a lot of narrative threads
occurring at any given time.
As a general rule, they're included to leave
writers with the option to go back to them
in the future if they want to - but that doesn't
always end up immediately being the case.
Some plot threads can be forgotten, and some
can just take a lot of time to resolve.
This can leave audiences with a lot of questions
- and not all of them end up being answered.
The Marvel Cinematic Universe is no exception
to this.
Thirteen movies have been released in the
MCU to date and there have been loads of plot
threads that writers have yet to go back to.
Granted, we know that some of them will be
revisited, but not all of them will be, and
it can be frustrating having to wait to see
them resolved in either case.
On that note, here are ten Marvel movies mysteries
that need answers badly (and please bear in
mind there are spoilers for Captain America:
Civil War in this video).
What Are The Infinity War Movies Going To
Be Called?
At the start of May in 2016, it was revealed
by director brothers Anthony and Joe Russo
that the two Avengers: Infinity War movies
will be renamed before they are released in
2018 and 2019 respectively.
But what will they be renamed to?
The only clue the Russos gave about the new
names is that they would be different to each
other and not just called "Part One" and "Part
Two" any more.
This is extremely intriguing, but with no
timescale on the renaming being given, fans
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe are going
to have to be patient for an answer to that
question.
What Actually Happened To The Red Skull?
At the end of 2011's Captain America: The
First Avenger, Hugo Weaving's Red Skull attempted
to handle the Tesseract and met his demise
- but exactly what kind of demise was it?
The immediate assumption was that he had died,
but the Tesseract is the Infinity Stone that
enables travel across the universe, so was
the Red Skull simply transported to a distant
location in the cosmos?
He has yet to re-emerge in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe, but speculation about a possible
return has been rife for years.
Should he ever return, fans of the franchise
would finally learn exactly what happened
to him.
Does Atlantis Exist In The MCU?
Towards the end of 2010's Iron Man 2, Tony
Stark receives a debriefing from Nick Fury
at a S.H.I.E.L.D. facility.
In the room are a number of high-tech computer
screens with important information displayed
on them.
One of the screens has a map of the world
on it with a number of key locations highlighted
on it; these include Wakanda and what appears
to be Atlantis.
Wakanda has, of course, been confirmed to
exist in the MCU, but six years on we still
haven't seen Atlantis introduced.
Does it actually exist in the MCU?
It would be very cool if it does, because
we might get to see the introduction of Namor
the Sub-Mariner, but who knows if we'll ever
find out?
Where Is The Real Mandarin?
2013's Iron Man 3 introduced a villain that
caused a lot of anger among comic book movie
fans.
The Mandarin was initially believed to be
the same bad guy who so famously fights Iron
Man on a regular basis in the comics, but
Iron Man 3 put a controversial twist on the
character.
The Mandarin was revealed to be a ruse portrayed
by bumbling British actor Trevor Slattery,
created to allow Guy Pearce's Aldrich Killian
to go about his villainous business undisturbed.
However, Marvel Studios backtracked due to
the fan reaction, and revealed in the Marvel
One-Shot All Hail the King that the real Mandarin
is still out there.
But where is he?
Are we ever going to see him?
Only time will tell, but it doesn't look likely
at the moment.
How Does Erik Selvig Know So Much?
In 2013's Thor: The Dark World, Stellan Skarsgård's
Erik Selvig was revealed to have been driven
mad by the events of 2012's The Avengers - a
movie in which Loki mind-controlled him using
his mysterious scepter.
In his crazed state, the institutionalised
Selvig drew a diagram of the World Tree on
a chalkboard that included references to "The
Fault" and "The Crossroads".
Fans of Marvel Comics will know that these
are both cosmic gateways to an infinite number
of alien dimensions and alternate universes.
But how the hell does Selvig know about them?
What exactly did Loki put in his head?
Where exactly had he been taken by the God
of Mischief?
We'll probably never know.
What's Happend To Odin?
At the end of the aforementioned Thor: The
Dark World, when Loki was believed to be dead,
the God of Mischief actually revealed himself
to be sat on the throne belonging to his adopted
father Odin.
Loki had used his magical illusions to disguise
himself as the All-Father and had clearly
disposed of Anthony Hopkins' character in
some way.
Since then, Odin's whereabouts hasn't been
confirmed.
Is he dead?
Is he being held captive somewhere?
Did Loki hand him over to the Mad Titan, Thanos,
as a way of apologising for his failure to
conquer Earth in The Avengers?
Surely we'll find out the answer to this question
in 2017's Thor: Ragnarok.
How Do The Avengers Still Not Know Phil Coulson's
Alive?
In the aforementioned Avengers movie in 2012,
it's fair to say that the death of Phil Coulson
was pivotal in the coming together of the
fractured titular team in order for them to
defeat Loki and his invading Chitauri army.
Tony Stark and his fellow heroes weren't going
to let Clark Gregg's likeable character die
in vain, so they put their differences aside,
convened in New York City, and kicked some
alien ass.
Soon after that victory, it was revealed in
television's Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D. that Coulson
had been resurrected.
Nearly four years on, the Avengers still don't
know that he's alive again.
How?
Both the Avengers and Coulson's team of S.H.I.E.L.D.
agents make it their business to intervene
in the exploits of super-powered villains
around the globe - and Coulson often does
it in broad daylight - so it's crazy to think
his friends and allies in the Avengers aren't
aware that he's not still dead.
Who Is Peter Quill's Father?
Guardians of the Galaxy was one of 2014's
most successful movies, and it will be getting
a 2017 sequel as a result.
This is great news, as we already know that
it will answer a question that fans badly
want answering.
It was revealed in the first movie that Peter
Quill's father - someone Yondu described as
a "jackass" - was something more than human,
and that's why Peter was able to withstand
the power of the Orb Infinity Stone.
The movie ended on that cliffhanger, which
was really frustrating.
But it has now been confirmed that none other
than Kurt Russell will be playing Quill's
dad in Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 2.
We really can't wait to find out which character
he's playing!
Where Are All The Avengers Now?
At the end of the aforementioned Civil War
movie, a lot of questions were left unanswered
regarding where certain Avengers were.
Captain America broke Clint Barton, Wanda
Maximoff, Sam Wilson and Scott Lang out of
the Raft prison, but where that quartet disappeared
to afterwards is unclear.
Black Widow also had to go on the run after
helping Cap and Bucky Barnes escape from the
authorities, so it's only known where a few
of the Avengers are.
Tony Stark, James Rhodes and Vision remain
at the Avengers facility in Upstate New York,
Spider-Man is back home in Queens and Captain
America is in Wakanda with Black Panther and
Bucky Barnes.
When you also bear in mind that Hulk and Thor's
whereabouts are still unknown after the events
of 2015's Avengers: Age of Ultron, fans really
want to know where a lot of the Avengers are.
Did Spider-Man Sign The Sokovia Accords?
2016's Captain America: Civil War saw the
Marvel Cinematic Universe debut of Spider-Man.
The movie had Team Iron Man and Team Captain
America fighting over the implementation of
the Sokovia Accords; a legislative bill that
required superhumans to register as such and
be managed by the governments of the world.
The Webslinger fought on Tony Stark's pro-registration
side, but did he actually sign the Accords?
He wasn't present for any discussions about
it and it was never made clear.
It's really hard to imagine Spider-Man only
operating on the streets of New York when
the government tell him to - that's just not
how Spider-Man classically operates - and
his first MCU solo movie in 2017 will definitely
have a bizarre feel to it if that turns out
to be the case.
Thanks for watching our list of 10 Marvel
movie mysteries that need answers badly.
Do you want the answers to these questions?
Did we leave any major examples out?
Let us know in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one!